remember Daily Motion 10 to 15 years ago
Daily Motion was one of the leading
video sharing Platforms in the entire
world after YouTube of course they were
often much slower than YouTube at taking
down copyrighted content they also had
looser rules regarding when a frequent
copyright infringer would actually be
taken off the platform which made them a
Honeypot for cartoons TV shows and
movies in fact just a couple of years
ago Daily Motion was finded 5.5 million
for precisely this and that was just one
of several occasions but with the rise
of affordable streaming services like
Netflix and Disney plus and the utter
domination of YouTube daily motion has
largely fallen into the Shadows or at
least that's what you would think it
turns out that Daily Motion is still
quite popular amongst the demographic
outside of Western countries in November
of 2023 for example much of their web
traffic came from India Indonesia Egypt
and Vietnam which added up to a total of
582 million visitors to be fair YouTube
enjoyed
117 billion visitors so Daily Motion
obviously does not even come close to
YouTube pulling in just 0.5% of the
traffic with that being said though
Daily Motion is still very much a giant
in its own right but that's pretty much
the only thing that Daily Motion still
has going for themselves at this point
in mid 2015 a French media holding
company called vendi bought out the vast
majority of daily motion for just $241
million
for perspective Google bought YouTube
for over five times that price nearly 10
years earlier and it's not like Daily
Motion was late to the video streaming
game either they were actually founded
way back in March of 2005 just 30 days
after YouTube but Daily Motion never
enjoyed the same growth or success of
YouTube or even Vimeo who at one point
ipoed at $8.5 billion since then Theo's
valuation has fallen
93% but they're still worth over twice
tce as much as what Daily Motion was
acquired for so here's the tragic story
of one of the OG video streaming
platforms Daily
[Music]
Motion taking a look back the story of
Daily Motion dates back to a French man
named Benjamin babo Ben was born on
November 20th 1976 in Paris friends to a
family of doctors despite his academic
lineage though Ben was never the biggest
fan of school in fact he would quickly
develop a reputation of being that one
lazy kid that skipped school too much
and got suspended but despite his Antics
he did manage to get pretty good grades
and would eventually graduate with
honors with a degree in mathematics and
information Sciences he didn't really
have much interest in pursuing
mathematics as a career path though in
fact throughout his college Years he had
actually picked up a habit of late night
gaming which quickly turned into Ben
teaching himself how to code and
creating his own websites and games but
while he enjoyed pursuing these projects
they didn't exactly pay the bills so he
would end up picking up a bunch of odd
jobs throughout the late 1990s this
included helping tourists being a
telemarketer and working in the Telecom
industry feeling lost Ben would
eventually return to college at which
point he was approached by a cafe
manager the manager was looking to put
together a website for his Cafe and felt
that Ben was the perfect guy to do it
and that's when everything clicked for
Ben
what he needed to do was create a web
design studio and help local businesses
create their own websites he would team
up with one of his cousins and together
they would create iguana studio in 2000
over the next couple of years iguana
Studio would evolve into being a decent
personal business allowing Ben to take a
vacation to New York in 2005 and it was
here that the idea for Daily Motion was
born you see Ben had taken some videos
of the snowfall in Manhattan and wanted
to share it with his friends and family
back in Paris but to to his surprise
there was no easy way to share large
video files over the Internet so as soon
as he returned home he would team up
with one of his friends Olivier poetry
and whoop up a simple s to share videos
online called short. TV initially this
was much more of a public service as
opposed to a serious business but to the
duo surprise the website would quickly
pick up quite a bit of momentum within
France at this point short. TV was very
much just something that these two were
running out of petry's apartment so to
accommodate for this influx in traffic
they would raise a modest €6,000 from
six people and they would rename the
website to Daily Motion Daily Motion
never experienced the same scale of
growth that YouTube enjoyed but they
were growing pretty fast within France
in fact just 18 months after being
founded Daily Motion would lock in the
largest French Web 2.0 fundraising round
of 2006 worth €7 million just a few
months after this Google would buy
YouTube for $1.65 billion dollar which
pushed daily motion's investors to
double down on their bet in 2007 they
would provide Daily Motion with another
€25 million in funding to try their hand
at Global expansion but while they had
access to a large amount of capital the
reality was that no amount of money is
Ever Enough in the world of free online
video streaming and the Daily Motion
team would learn this firsthand as they
faced challenge after
challenge
with little to no content moderation
Daily Motion would almost immediately be
dragged into the world of copyright
litigation in fact just 2 years after
founding the company Daily Motion would
get bogged down with their first
copyright infringement lawsuit they
tried to argue that they were just a
Content platform not an active infringer
of copyright regulation but this
argument didn't hold up in court the
Court ruled that Daily Motion was very
much aware of the copyrighted content
being uploaded load it onto their
platform and as such it was up to them
to remove it in a timely manner not
exactly the ruling that they were
looking for but it's not like they had
time to appeal every single day Daily
Motion was burning boatloads of money
keeping the website up and running for
millions of people to use for free so
their number one priority was to get
monetization up and running so that they
could at least offset some of their
losses however this was a lot easier
said than done you see in the late 2000s
instream video ads like the one you
probably saw before this video weren't
even a thing all you had were the static
display ads that you saw on websites
advertisers were also rather skeptical
about digital advertising in general so
Daily Motion was stuck showing display
ads on a video platform which as you
would guess was not all that lucrative
as such Daily Motion was quickly back to
the fundraising table in 2009 the good
news though was that they were able to
get some pretty reputable backers such
as the French government themselves who
invested 17 million into the platform
just as daily emotion was getting back
on their feet though they would be hit
with not just another lawsuit but an
outright ban from India in May of
2012 fortunately India would roll back
this ruling in the following months
citing that only certain URLs should be
blocked for copyright infringement not
entire websites this event made Daily
Motion realized that they not only
needed allies within France but around
the world so they would form
Partnerships with several International
media Publications including Hurst media
and Bloomberg they would also open
offices in London San Francisco and
Singapore this may have given them a
better reputation within the business
world but it didn't exactly stop at the
lawsuits in fact their home City itself
would find them for € 1.3 million in
late 2014 this was followed by another
temporary ban in India and a permanent
ban in Russia throughout this entire
time period Daily Motion was basically
just juggling three things over and over
again they were addressing copyright
infringement lawsuits trying to raise
money and then solving issues with scale
after that they would once again address
copyright infringement lawsuits raise
capital and solve issues with scale this
vicious cycle repeated over and over
again up until
2017 by this point streaming services
were really taking off so most copyright
holders turned their focused on
monetizing streaming services instead of
going after Daily Motion but while this
fine gave Daily Motion a break this was
also accompanied by a large outflow of
users which brings us into the
modern-day Daily
[Music]
Motion honestly I don't think Daily
Motion ever really wanted to be some
sort of piracy streaming Center other
sites like mega upload very much leaned
into this Persona and used it to
maximize profits Daily Motion on the
other hand was truly just was trying to
create a competitor to YouTube but it
just so happened that piracy is what its
users often turn to Daily Motion for
much of this just had to do with the
immense resources that YouTube had
thanks to Google they had advertisers
the ability to stomach insane losses the
Google ecosystem massive infrastructure
and the ability to pay out creators as
such YouTube was the Clear Choice for
regular videos and the Daily Motion
naturally became a place that hosted
content that was not available on
YouTube which mainly consisted of
copyrighted content this put Daily
Motion in a really tricky situation did
they turn a blind eye to copyrighted
content to pump up their user base or do
they continue with their Noble efforts
it seems that da motion was stuck in a
constant limbo between these two efforts
as they fought one lawsuit after another
and eventually a decision was forced
upon them when streaming took off with
affordable streaming services being
available most people simply had no
reason to use an offbrand version of
YouTube anymore as such the interest in
Daily Motion slowly bled out throughout
the second half of the 2010s it seems
that the founders somewhat expected this
as they very much made decisions that
would protect themselves from this
outcome in fact Ben was already taking
steps out the door by mid 2008 when he
stepped down from being CEO and he would
completely cash out of the company at
roughly 120 million valuation in the
early 2010s it's not clear how much of
the company he still owned at this point
but if it was any sizable amount he
likely walked away with tens of millions
of Euros since then it seems that Ben
has circled all the way back to
academics as he is now a professor of
python at the Albert School in Paris
after that Olivier would score a job at
Netflix as director of engineering and
if you didn't know Netflix pays 1.2
million cash for directors of software
engineering so I think it's safe to say
that the founders are fortunately doing
better than ever the same however cannot
be said about Daily Motion over the
years there were some brief moments of
great hope for the company for example
in 2014 Microsoft nearly invested in
Daily Motion something that may have
taken the platform to a whole another
level what did end up happening though
was vendi buying out Daily Motion for
roughly $300 million since then daily
motion has really just been running on
fumes the main reason that there's still
somewhat popular today is largely just
because they used to be popular and with
Daily Motion making decisions like
removing the comment section and even
the view counter altogether largely
because their videos weren't getting any
views things don't look so bright for
Daily Motion moving forward best case
scenario they'll be tossed from one
owner to another just like AOL or Yahoo
while they still have some juice left
eventually though that juice will run
out at which point the platform will be
completely shut down and that is the
tragic fate of daily emotion another OG
video platform that's facing a similar
fate is Vimeo check out this video to
learn more but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next
one